so this is the mask and it was thought
up by the students last year when there
was a mask
shortage here in thailand and the
important bit really is this side dotty
panel which is covered
with a thermochromic coating and what
that means is when the person wearing it
gets
hotter than 37.5 degrees this changes
color and the front bit here is also
covered with a water repellent coating
so if someone was to sneeze on you those
droplets wouldn't go through but let me
show you some of the technology in
action here so first of all this is the
water repellent coating let's see if it
works
water coming yep you can see that's not
going through at all so
none of those infectious droplets would
be brought into your mark then here
we've got them putting on the second
that
special thermochromic coating and what
happens is the original material would
be like this red and white
they then put this coating on two layers
they dry it
and that really is the magic of this
mask and we can see it working in action
now this is a heated mannequin so i'll
put the mask on it and
where you need to be watching really is
these side areas and you should start
seeing a change
in around 20 seconds you can already see
some of these dots here
are changing color and they're going
first from blue
to white because this outside coating is
changing to clear
and i can show you a bit more this is
similar technology so this has
got the dye on and if i put this on a
heated area you can see it changing
really quickly there and the reason that
they've chosen to use the coating
rather than the dye is because these
masks with the coating on can go in the
washing machine now these are just
prototypes
they've only been working on this for a
few months but they cost
around two pound to make and the big
plan in the future is to try and roll
this out to the thai public so if you're
wearing it
you get that initial sign on your mask
that your fever's gone up